[Music]
this
is star talk and i'm your host neil
degrasse tyson your personal
astrophysicist
and today this is a star talk devoted
to the first man adam
[Music]
that was chuck nice my co-host of the
first man
special edition of star talk we're of
course talking about neil armstrong
and his first steps on the moon and
we're not going to do that unless we
bring in
an astronaut wow i mean in a cool i got
on my roller decks i got some astronauts
wow
and one of my favorites actually is my
favorite but i don't want to tell you oh
that's nice
mike massimino mike neil dude thanks for
coming chuck
thanks for having me i'm so glad i could
uh this was on short notice we saw each
other
just the other night yeah uh both we saw
a preview screening of the
film first man all about neil armstrong
and i realized
it's not about neil armstrong it is neil
armstrong's view
yeah right it's his p the point of view
of who
he was who he was they captured his his
personality
what he was about the way he approached
his work yeah it was i thought it was
fantastic let me finish introducing you
so you're a former nasa astronaut
yes you're a mechanical engineer you're
professor columbia university
and you're a senior space advisor to the
intrepid sea air and space museum
thank you for mentioning all those
things and your wife and dad i mean your
husband and dad
yes yes correct the wife that the
operation is later
he's wife on tuesdays
so uh nobody thanks for making time for
coming in for this uh
i'm really thrilled to be here yeah
always good to see you guys especially
with to talk about my boyhood hero
so did you guys know neil armstrong can
i finish introducing oh you're still in
this introduction
sorry holy moly you're a veteran of two
space flights
uh sts which is nasa code for
space transportation system correct
oh cool it actually makes sense does it
i think it's called shuttle mission 109.
and in 2002 and 125 that was a good one
in may 2009 the last servicing mission
of the hubble telescope
giving it life into the 2010s that's
right and you had four spacewalks
yep and you're the okay
he's the first man unto himself yes he
is the first man to
tweet from space
takes that neil armstrong yeah okay so
neil armstrong said
one small step for man one giant leap
for mankind what were your first tweet
from space yeah that's the problem
there's now there's a neil armstrong
story here
related to it okay if we want to go
there yeah go go
very first time neil armstrong came the
first to speak to my astronaut class we
were there for a total of four days so
you're still like an astronaut
yeah we were just getting like he was
newbies he happened to be in town for
his physical
our training manager in houston right at
the johnson space center all new
astronauts
and and she asked him what uh paige
molsby was her name she asked she went
get a message over the clinic would he
come speak to us and he said he would
but he only wanted to speak to the new
astronauts
so he came over and talked to us mainly
about
uh flying in the x-15 and we asked some
questions the x-15
the test uh plane from nasa yeah based
on a
military uh i mean it's a it's a
rocket a super rocket supersonic yeah
rocket plane yeah and it's it was one of
the more it's
i don't know maybe the most successful
experimental aircraft ever ever built it
then went like mach
7 a couple of those guys seven times the
speed of sound yeah and
a couple of those guys earned their
astronaut wings for having
altitude yeah that's how high this
airplane could go it could get you to
what no
space is an arbitrary boundary that's
another story right but uh but they were
able to earn astronaut wings in that
earth itself is in space yes yes it's
simple
have you ever been supposed to know yes
i hate to bring this up because then you
will have a whole nother show going
right about the boundary of space but
but an amazing air aircraft he talked
about that in other things and we got to
meet him and talk to him but the day
after we were at a um
it was like a luncheon going on because
there was a reunion as well as him
coming in for his physical
and i ended up next to him on the food
line you know making a sandwich
damn it had to go on a chow line wow
that's cold that didn't even seem right
that's not that's wrong you know it
wasn't bad food though even though it
was government food it wasn't
anyway so he's next to me i you know i'm
i had i said to myself
i had to say something to this guy
because i'm next to him i don't know how
it happened but serendipitously
and i asked him when did you think of
that first thing that you
said on the moan though one small step
for man would i go did you know did your
wife tell you did you get a publicist
who how'd you come up with this and he
turned to me he says well mike i thought
about it only after
we landed because if we didn't land i
wouldn't have to say anything it
wouldn't make a difference
and so i concentrated only on the
landing saved his brain energy
well yeah but i think what he was the
message he was trying to get to me as a
new astronaut
um or i don't know if he was trying but
the message i took was you take care of
business first
and you worry about that worry about
other stuff later right so his his focus
was landing on the moon
so for my tweet i did the same approach
i'm not going to worry about this first
tweet
we have to we have to launch into space
we have to get there
alive and successfully i got a mistake i
got a job to do no big mistake sounds
like a mistake
this was a mystery so i get there and
it's all right we're alive and it's time
to just computers are up and running on
day one
and so i need to come up with something
so what i what i said what i tweeted was
launch was awesome the adventure of a
lifetime has begun i'm feeling great
enjoying the view
something like long but the first the
first it was okay but during the
during the mission um i i
you know i was paying attention to the
mission of course during the mission
aside aside bars i didn't get any email
from my kids
my kids were they were both teenagers
you mentioned i'm a father yes
i love my kids they were both but but
they were very happy that i was away
from the planet at that time and they
were ignoring me and i'm writing them
you know well they couldn't they could
have taken it personally
some dads go in a business no no no you
left planet earth
they were happy i was away and they were
like dad annoying dad can't bother us
anymore
and i wasn't getting anything in new
york was he in space which is
well they knew i wasn't there and they
were just happy enough they didn't want
to be reminded
so i wasn't getting an email from
saturday comes
saturday comes and saturday night live
makes fun of this tweet neil and this
was an 09 so it's the 40th anniversary
of the
of the of the almost a fourth
anniversary of apollo 11.
and uh seth meyers on snl says we have
the first tweet from space mike
massimino
uh and here it is launch was awesome
in 40 years we've gone from one giant
leap for mankind
to launch was awesome if we ever find
life in the universe i assume this is
how we'll be notified
and it shows my little twitter thing and
it says jeez dudes aliens
so they made fun of me and my kids
finally sent my email on that monday
right they sent me emailing that monday
and i was there after the spacewalks
wrote like dad i thought thanks for
saving the hubble you did great no
it was dad they made fun of you on
saturday night live
all the kids at school loved it keep
saying stupid stuff
so i don't think neil armstrong ever got
a reaction like that from his kids on
that but he's so
so that was the first that was bad
advice for you
uh no it was still good advice i still
think it's good advice because his
advice was you take care of business
first
and that's what you concentrate on and i
think that's the way that
the way he was and i think that's why he
was chosen to be the first man
if only he had followed it up with and
make sure you schedule your tweets
yeah um also uh this story and others
you can find in your book
space man yes baseball thank you yeah
thanks for that
thanks man that's a plug it's a yes it
is a plug but it's yeah
that's it's authentically i conceived
uh you're a great storyteller and i love
the book thank you
and you didn't fix the cover photo
though because you're sitting there
smiling right now and there's a
rocket coming out of your ear that's
launched behind well i was told the
publishers in charge of the
you can have input for the cover but
they i was in charge of the words and
it looked like you had ear racks with
the i know and i've heard and that in
fact if you see that
i've heard other comments which we can't
mention about what that looks like so
yes i agree
um so the two of us saw our
pre-screening of first man
and everything i know
about neil armstrong because i knew him
i mean
i don't claim i knew him well we weren't
beer drinking buddies but i mean we
were acquaintances i should say and
everything i knew about him and i think
is true for you all you knew about him
all that you knew of him
was consistent with how he was portrayed
in this film would you agree
absolutely yeah everything that i knew
about him so give me your best
characterization of him because some
people don't even know that
i i would i would say that um
he loved he loved flying airplanes he
loved doing his job he loved being a
tesla he was a fighter test
he was a fighter a pilot first in korea
yep then test pilot
and a test spine he was he was i guess a
very thoughtful engineer but loved
flying
when he came and spoke to our astronaut
classical
but he saw he saw it as an engineering
problem as a challenge and that's why i
think he was not just a great pilot
because he loved flying but also
a great test pilot because he enjoyed
the engineering behind it
and uh that's that was pretty impressive
i think
i had never thought about that yeah you
could be fly boys say give me that
machine i'll do what i get
if you're an engineer you're thinking
about the machine right and if the
aerodynamics yes
if you're really into that like he was
uh i think it was
it was this in and not all great
engineers i think can make
great pilots but he was one of those
that could and i think that's where you
have a really special test pilot and do
they ever make a change to the uh plane
and uh
or and he says no that ain't
that ain't gonna work i'm sure he chimed
in i would i would
i would expect that those conversations
were made and especially back in those
days when they were
doing things that were much different uh
than
what they had ever done before and how
fast they were going how high they were
going what they were trying to achieve
when his pet the test pilot days uh
there was i'm sure there was a lot of
those conversations yeah
so uh i would add to that that neil
armstrong was
was not gregarious he was a very quiet
man
yeah did not seek publicity did not you
know
he's not the person who'd say is the
life of the party but sometimes the
people who are not the life of the party
are sitting there doing nothing
he's sitting there in his head figuring
stuff out it's the active
restless brain of the engineer yeah and
so
this was surely captured that was him
and when i first met him neil you
you described that really well uh when
he got up there in front of our we all
stood up and gave him a standing ovation
and just about all i was one of the
younger people in that group of
new astronauts in 96 so just about
everyone in that room
maybe one or two wouldn't remember
remembered where they were and he
that he and that episode of
what he did landing on the moon that
whole mission inspired most of us to
become astronauts i would say we all
remembered it
and so you're meeting your hero we're
meeting our hero and it was just me it
was everybody and he was he's the man
right he was
he was the man and he gets up there and
was it seemed almost like he was
painfully shy
almost said it was hard for him to talk
and he
he didn't mention the moon at all he
talked about test flying and how
important that is
and how you have to be diligent about it
and and how much he loved doing that
and after he was done when we got the
questions and answers and we started
asking what was it like on the moon
but up to that point he was delivering
that message almost
painfully shy but he was so he loved so
so much what he did and felt it was so
important that that's what he focused on
he was the right man for the job
do you think nasa
chose him to be the first on the moon
because of all of this
because he does not seek publicity
because because if they got
some grandstanding yeah yo look at me
i'm on the moon
here's my book about me being on the
moon here's my talk show
interview i've got a need for speed
you mean like if it was one of us
do you think yeah they thought that
through i i think that
uh what needed someone humble you know i
i that
that seems like a you know i i used to
think that and maybe at first but
i think lately in the last few years
i've changed my my my thinking of it
because i think that's almost too much
thinking i think really what they wanted
to do no really you know
i think what they were looking for was
the guy that was just too much thinking
no
you started i guess you start you start
thinking too many things like oh this
guy has wearing blue and this guy you
know
you overthink it i think what they what
they saw was
this was the right man to to land on the
moon whether or not he was gregarious
whether or not he was shy
whether or not whatever those
personalities were
he was the right man because he
understood what was happening
he was going to focus on that job 100
percent
not be distracted and maybe that has
partly to do with the fame seeking but i
think really he was chosen not for that
for the personality part of it but
because he was the right man
to do that job did they choose who
actually got out of the capsule
first i mean yeah but he was the mission
lead as well
the commission commander yes he was the
commander so
it wasn't because he was commander that
he got to go first they actually made
the choice like
you're going to be the first to step
foot on the moon and your commander and
your commander
like those are two separate things you
think yeah and something like for
example it could have been like in star
trek
you go check out the glowing blob first
buzz you check see that glowing thing
report back to me
right and then i'll step off though and
that's true
but that's the way that's the way we did
it now that you're saying it
that's why i space walked apparently
because that's what we would do in the
shuttle program the commander and the
pilot
would not go out in spacewalk the
mission specialist would and the
underlying one of the underlying
mission specialist is someone who has an
expertise usually a scientific or an
engineering expertise
brought into the service of the mission
correct so you're not flying a plane
out there you're not going to land i
mean we're part of landing but we're
actually going to land
right because the idea is what happens
if your commander goes out and doesn't
come back who's going to land
right uh but it's okay if you go out and
don't come back you can still land
i hate to put it that way but yes you
don't have to put it out
there was a lost crewman there was a
line everything you would check like all
right
this is in place you know this check
that check that checked and part of the
briefing was lost crewman
and lost crewman was a procedure we had
to go rescue a guy that comes lost and
what we would do
sort of kidding around was lost crewman
don't worry about it we got three more
that's what we have because we have four
space walkers so that was like the joke
and we'd all laugh but on the line like
you know you can come get me
but then we were gonna do that if we
needed um what were we talking about
with the commander who ran out first
commander and traditionally i think in
in gemini what they did was is that the
commander gemini
what's up two two astronaut capsules
right and that's when they first
spacewalked ed white was the first
spacewalker
and and buzz was one of the one of the
last space walkers in gemini
but i think it was traditionally the
commander stayed inside yeah thank you
but uh
mainly the command i think the tradition
was the commander stayed inside
and it was the pilot who went out and
then came back because the only one guy
at a time going
so this was a different case where
you're going to have both people going
out for the
for the for the walk wow yeah part of
the authenticity
of the film was their little details
that they didn't have to really care
about
but they did yes so there's a moment i
ha i happened to
own an omega watch that was gifted to me
by stephen hawking wow and that's pretty
nice
yeah i don't mean a name drop i was
going to say i just like the fact that
you didn't name drugs
i've got one too but i had to buy it
myself right so
no i got a stephen hawking watch too and
he just doesn't know i have it
we got his watch yeah he was just
walking around just like yeah
[Laughter]
so it was gifted to you by you
exactly so uh no i got the stephen
hawking award for science communication
and just so it's only like a year old
but but
this is cool man this introduced me to
omega watches and omega was the first
watch
on the moon right they were chosen by
nasa after nasa got all the
all the premiere what the rolex uh
breitling what whatever whatever
whatever the top watches were today i i
wonder if they threw in the timex i
don't know just
just to get america in there i bet so
they that's what they're sure they did
okay so they throw it in probably still
on the moon taking a licking and keeping
them on tape
nobody remembers that advertisement it
was a wind-up
so in fact the yeah the moon watch was
all lined up
yes so they put them all in black boxes
each and scrambled them
and then shake them baked them heated
them radiated them and at the end of the
experiments the omega still had the
correct time
so mega is our watch and so they still
milk that today with their advertising
yeah but any event
in this festival that i attended the
star miss festival that hawking is a
organizer of uh uh omega was one of the
sponsors and so
this became the watch yes it's in great
it's engraved on the back yeah but i saw
a i watched it look very much like this
on neil armstrong's hands right here in
the movie it's right there i'm wearing
it you're wearing it you're wearing that
right yeah i have shoulders
did you get this from from being an
astronaut no no
this okay so we had uh we had omega
watchers on the shuttle and the way it
was explained to us like how they won
that competition was the crystal
apparently that crystal that they had on
top was almost impenetrable
and uh you could do whatever you wanted
to it it wasn't going to crack so
particles are a problem
so that's why and with moonglass how do
you wind the watch well i think you have
to do
wind it ahead of time we had a different
omega that we had
we had a different we winded ahead of
time we had a different omega uh for the
shuttle this is the moon version i had a
different one that i had a purchase
now omega was willing i think to give us
these watches for free but it was a
government program
and nasa said not so fast so we had a we
had to buy our watches but we were able
to purchase them from omega and then fly
them i'm not wearing my
my shuttle watch and i'm wearing a moon
watch that yes i had to go into the
omega store and buy man that is
messed up man no no no you can't
otherwise you can be it's all right yeah
it's the right it's the right thing
that's how you want it yeah you don't
want it no no it's the right thing
we gotta take a break yeah we gotta take
a break you are listening to possibly
even watching star talk
this is our first man edition
celebrating the life
and the first steps on the moon of neil
armstrong we'll be right back
thanks to curiosity stream for
supporting this episode of star talk
we're 50 years past the first apollo
moon landing but we never stuck around
we just kept going and leaving like a
great romantic relationship
curiosity stream's return to the moon
tells the story of how we're going back
to the moon and this time
how we'll stay for good learn about how
helium-3 from the moon can power the
earth for
years to come and how the future of
lunar colonies will look from conception
to completion
this curiosity stream documentary made
me want to go to the moon and listen to
a little pink floyd
some of you know what i'm talking about
subscribe to curiositystream to watch it
now
it's just 2.99 per month and for star
talk fans the first 31 days are
completely free when you
sign up at curiositystream.com
star talk and use promo code star talk
you'll get
unlimited access to the world's top
documentaries and non-fiction series
with curiosity stream
sign up now we're back on star talk
first man edition
who's the first man neil armstrong first
man on the moon got our
friend of star talk mike massimino he's
been in space twice
one of them to repair my hubble space
telescope i love you man for that
thank you you're welcome
chuck nice co-host chuck yes and i've
been in space
i'm still in space i'm still in space
space out and space two different things
two different things um
i was asked back in 2009 to
host to emcee
the 40th anniversary of the apollo
landing
1969 plus 40 gets you to 2009. it was in
the air and space museum mike you're
what i did in front you told you just
you moon walked well i had
every living moonwalker in the audience
and
some interesting things i remember i'm
sorry you went through the
moonwalking thing no no i don't remember
what i said i know you said you said
something about being the 40th
yeah anniversary yeah and you were
saying how 40 was
an interesting number because oh 50 you
might not you know and we've lost so
many of those guys
between then and now mm-hmm wow and you
did the moonwalk
which which happened you know i don't
dance let's go back to the 40s
because that sounds a little you know
provocative
no so what i try to remember this is
when i said it 40 is an interesting
number because
in many stories they don't track it
beyond 40.
so 40 days and 40 nights correct it's
not
50 days and 50 nights 40 days and 40
nights jesus got 39 lashes
not 40 because 40 that's like infinite
right you got to bring that in
okay you don't want to kill him you just
want to hurt him
oh that's the one last that would have
did it switched
just the number 40 shows up especially
biblically yes
okay and it's a so when you pass 40
it's like more time than historically
people
reckoned okay you sort of you know 1
through 40 and then infinity
beyond that and so beyond that it's like
okay is it still there for us to
remember or do we have to be reminded of
it
whereas if it's within 40 you can talk
about it people are alive they were
conscious they were
adults they were so that makes sense
that's two generations basically yeah
beyond two years
you're stepping into that you're
stepping into the next generation and
that makes perfect sense okay
i think that set the mood at the time
that this was a really special night and
at the
at that time in this event afterwards
uh star trek talk was in our first year
and i said this is a target of
opportunity for me to get a bunch of
interviews and we can make a show out of
this
so i waited till the event was over and
we had a reception and all of this
and i got interviews
with various key people in the space
program at the time as well as some
old timers like neil armstrong and he
never gives interviews yeah
have you ever seen him interviewed on tv
no that's one of the things he's known
for is not
it's not being a big talker here's why i
think he granted me the interview
because moon walked
[Laughter]
i first met him when i was 14.
oh on board the ss canberra
on route from new york city to the coast
of northwest africa
holy cow to observe the total solar
eclipse
the longest in the century and he was
one of the various
sort of important people brought on
board right first they would enjoy the
eclipse but also they were there for the
rest of us
to interact with and this is 1973 and
you're fourteen
he's four fourteen are you kidding
yourself yeah i'm by myself all right i
lied to you
stolen what did you do yeah i was gonna
say what were you stole away yes
did your parents know you were going on
this thing they're like wait my parents
didn't even let me take the subway back
then by myself why does that
there were 1500 people they they took
off all the shuffleboard
and the lounge chairs and it was a
forest of tripods
on this the whole ship was a scientific
floating vessel wow and he was there
that's when i met isaac and various
other sort of
heroes if you're a geek kid right in the
day
wow and now that he was sitting here you
were
let's you were king geek okay
you were king of all geeks because yeah
a deep kid is just like i can't believe
i just got this new trading card you're
like yeah i'm going to north africa
with neil armstrong like for the eclipse
you kidding me yeah all right go ahead
so he's sitting alone at the bar
and this is one year after the last
mission to the moon which is 1972.
it's four years after he walked on the
moon and he's a lot i said
you know mr armstrong and i had my my
ship program with his picture and the
thing
and i said would you mind signing what i
don't know could you sign
i think and so he signs it and and i
just said
thank you when i next saw him i showed
him that
that i was on this vessel and
i think he i don't know i don't want to
project
what he might be thinking but i think he
saw that
i i became no there's an instant
connection
you covered me all these years later
yeah with a signed program
right from a ship that shows stowed away
on so that you could go to north africa
and watch an eclipse
right that's pretty cool i would have
rather the story end it with him going
pull up a stool kid yeah
that's what it takes kids to get uh to
get an interview with neil armstrong
you know you're not just gonna well hey
i've got my press connection credentials
here no that's not working
so and it wasn't it was brief but i have
it and you'll see
he's not a you know he's smart and
calm and measured yeah and let's let's
check it out
it's my interview with neil armstrong
brief though it was uh
neil armstrong uh commander of the
apollo 11.
how old were you 40 years ago today uh
i was 38.93
excellent i love it and of the entire
apollo
era what's your most indelible memory it
could be your own walk but if not i just
curious most indelible memory was
approaching the moon and and flying
through the moon's shadow
so that the moon was eclipsing the sun
and we could see the
corona all around the moon it was not
circular it was elliptical which was a
big surprise i understand that
and then we could see the moon the dark
side of the moon of course
illuminated by earth light and we could
see
the craters and the valleys and the
plains
in a blue gray uh
three-dimensional view that was
spectacular
and and remarkable and but
uh imperceptible to a camera but the
human eye
was wonderful and the last question what
do you think what do you think nasa
should do next
uh i'm supporter of the nasa plan uh
and uh um just needs more money i
suppose but the the ideas are there
yeah i think the the uh the approach
they're on
is uh a good one i i like that it's a
very it's a very
that's very pilot the approach
they're a little a little below glide
slope but you know they're
going to get there all right neil
armstrong thanks for those uh three
questions
yeah very cool you guys never
interviewed and i felt like i was
even taking too much by asking just
those three questions
yeah and yeah i'm kind of guilty he was
really
into that second what's the indelible
you could
actually i can almost feel him
looking looking experiencing it yes
experience like it was really
you know very visceral doing his
recounting consider that's nothing
you're going to get on this side of the
moon
yeah right so it had to be the backside
because he studied he would have studied
all the
maps and the pictures and everything
right yeah and you know
one of the one of the things that uh
with that i noticed with the movie that
i liked my one of my favorite first
things first man movie um was that you
were able to see what it looked like and
i think they probably did it pretty
accurately
because the film that we had back then
in 1969 we had some but especially of
the approach and the landing
people they're like their cameras kind
of looking out that triangular window
and the dust kicks up but you really
don't get an appreciation
for what it was like to see outside can
you imagine now if we were able to do
that
with a bunch of gopros or whatever they
would stick on high-def cameras
we would see that that moonscape and
probably even the night passes
gopro every foot probably right you know
and
it's easy right you make the whole ship
out of
and even in the low light level on the
other side i'm sure they could have
found something you know they wouldn't
be able to do something
because just recently now we can get
great uh images of the of the planet at
night from from station for example and
it wasn't clear his point that the eye
catches it but the camera doesn't yeah
is because the eye
in one glimpse can get a very high
dynamic range of
so the moon can be very dim but the
solar corona could be very bright right
and you can see all that at once where
the camera
is going to commit to either the bright
corona or the dim
thing but you're not going to get both
and he's experiencing both and
that description he gave you uh allowed
us to picture what it was like
there's no there's no real good video of
that but his description of it is
but you can feel that this he'd rather
just not be
be interviewed right it's he's just want
to go on his way
yeah and but is that really the best
person to have
uh represent the fact that you have
walked on the surface of a celestial
body
that's a good question uh you know i've
heard one of us i heard mike collins
that at niels memorial mike cohen's the
third astronaut who didn't get to go
downtown
he was he was yeah he orbited uh in
lunar orbit
uh in the command module while neil and
neil armstrong buzz over on the
on the on the moon um i heard him uh
speak at the memorial i don't want to
misquote him but at neil's room
at neil armstrong's memorial when he
died and they had a memorial service for
him at the johnson space center
and he talked a little bit about that
about you know him being maybe you know
a shy and cerebral or whatever but he
was like well who would you
why wouldn't you want that why would you
this this man who was so qualified who
did such a great job
why would you want him to be anything
different than who he was and i think
that's
i think that that's he was the right man
to land on the moon and
i think that was what they were most
concerned with because no kidding
they weren't so sure they were coming
back from that mission they weren't sure
so sure they were going to be successful
apollo 12 and 13 11 12 and 13 all had
the same mission they all trained for
the same mission
because they weren't so sure 11 was
going to be successful
and then it was and then 12 had to come
up with something quick which was
different
than what they did on 11 but they all
trained for that same mission because
they weren't so sure 11 was going to be
was going to be successful what you're
saying is if 11 failed then
12 next up you try it right you're next
wow
that didn't work
a few different ways one not so that
they would get that they wouldn't come
back alive but they might not get down
to the surface and come back they would
have to abort
and then come back to earth so the it
was really important for them to to try
to get the right guy to be the first
guy and that's what they went with who's
the best guy to pull off the landing
especially
of of this and that's where he had ice
in his veins and by the way
there's a there's a misconception i
think about
the first comments from houston
after he says houston tranquility base
here eagle has landed
yep okay which means of course the first
word of the first comments from the moon
is houston
but there you go
actually there was some other contact
light and other things yeah
right but houston then says something
like congratulations got you have a
bunch of guys
down here who were about to turn blue
yeah that was
charlie duke okay yep you think they're
saying that because they just landed on
the moon that's not why they're saying
it
they were holding their breath that's
not yes they were holding their breath
but
it's not because they just landed on the
moon that's not why okay why would
okay so why were they about to turn wait
they were smurfs
i'm sorry because neo was not happy
with the original landing spot and he
only has a certain amount of fuel
to prevent himself from crashing down
onto the moon this is keeping them
buoyant
nope too many boulders there too many
boulders there and you see
that you see the fuel come down wait a
minute and then he keeps going i think
i'll go over there and
my boy is smooth looks like he's looking
for parking in midtown
he can't park there he can't i can't put
that right baby baby you think i can fit
in there
no let's try over there but if you don't
make it you got to go home
so then he finally finds a spot lance
there's like
one or two percent fuel left that's what
they
because if he got if he went to zero
because
if if if he lands
with fuel in a place that he could crash
because it's not level
that's bad if he keeps looking
you can't get home if he keeps looking
and runs out of fuel
he'll crash because he runs out of fuel
he might have aborted oh they could have
still aborted
yeah you just you just jumped in at that
point i think that's forgot about that
right forgot about that okay uh so which
is not a good deal
so he with just and they they capture
this in the film in the tension so
that's why everyone at mission control
was freaking out
because that's that's the mission might
not complete not because oh we're happy
you landed yes
we're all happy landed on the moon yeah
but we're having atlanta moon alive
yeah he was down to one he had a low low
fuel light came on
30-second fuel or whatever it was yeah
and uh
in the cadence of uh which is depicted
in the in the movie
but the cadence of uh what what you know
the calls he was getting from buzz you
know um
so many forward so many down and i think
he was talking about rates at that yeah
that's right that's right
right right forward yeah 5'4 to give him
an idea of how fast he was moving
forward
so because he's all out the window i
would think at that point and and that's
that's the cadence of him coming down
here and yeah
that's fascinating so so i got to agree
if your mission is to succeed
that has higher priority over any social
profile
or public relations yeah did you succeed
first and worry about the rest of that
later right and his yeah
his friends his colleagues have had john
young was still an astronaut when i
became an astronaut and
later walked on the moon alan bean was
his
office mate and his colleague as well
another moonwalker
and i've heard him and those other guys
say neil was the right guy for the job
if they had a pick out of who they knew
was going to get that job done
it was neil armstrong all right we're
going to take our next break
we're talking about first man that's the
first man on the moon neil armstrong
when star talk returns
this episode of star talk is brought to
you by curiosity stream
we're back star talk first man edition
we're celebrating
the life of neil armstrong and the moon
landing and his first
steps got mike massimino mike
neal very good uh you i'm just still
laughing chuckling at your first tweet
oh boy what was it yeah
golly i'm in space was that what it was
launch was awesome launch was awesome
yeah
you're right thought you meant lunch
was awesome no that was that was the
first day in space no lunch yet
you're not feeling that great yeah lunch
was awesome the next day
that's when i wrote about the macaroni
and cheese this first day was long so at
nasa there's a famous colorful character
called gene krantz
and he's the one who is portrayed
famously in the film apollo 13
saying what failure is not an option
failure is not an option i bumped into
can you say that in real life
yeah oh yeah well that's the legend okay
cool okay
and i bumped into him uh with a
microphone in tow
first year of star talk i'm getting all
the interviews from all these space
folks
at this celebration of nasa's 40th
anniversary for landing on the moon
right in 2009
let's pick up with my conversation with
gene krantz here with gene krantz
failure is not an option gene krantz
that's your middle name now
that's that's been a a good game plan
for most of my life i
i really uh came into the failure is not
an option
well after i started the the business of
stars and stripes forever
when i was going through uh flight
training i had a very bad night
my first night solo i suffered almost
disabling vertigo
and finally got back landed and the next
evening you got to go out and do it
again and there's a
story about you got to ride the horse
that threw you i was fortunate that uh
as i was sweating it out chain smoking
lucky strikes
the flightline public address system
came alive
checking it out for the saturday parade
and they played the stars and stripes
forever
i picked up my parachute aced that night
flight in fact i
aced the business as a cadet graduated
went to fighter weapons school and from
that day on
every day of my professional life
started with the stars and stripes
forever
there's a it's inspiring
everybody's got something that gets them
going for most people it's a cup of
coffee
neil i i start off with a cup of coffee
too but the
the stars and stripes it was it was
interesting i i looked for something
that
that very slowly builds the energy
builds the crescendos such that
when you hit each day's work
you're at the peak performance and you
remain there throughout the day i found
out that basically from my standpoint
psyching yourself up is the key to
success
believing that you can believing that
you will
and then when you fall down believing
that you can pick yourself
up and start all over again i would ask
you three
questions you ready how old were you 40
years ago today
i was uh 36 years old
i was a baby my team's in mission
control averaged age
26. the majority of those were kids
fresh out of college they had a couple
years training they grew up in the
gemini program
early apollo they lived through the
disastrous apollo on fire
and they became tough and competent and
that was the fuel the energy for the
fire that took us to the moon
what is your most indelible memory from
the entire apollo era
neil i
i would say the most indelible thing
were really many things they were the
personalities of the people
i had young kids that came in fresh out
of college
who had this dream of space i had the
engineers come in who developed the
initial trajectory work john llewellyn
and carl huss and tequin roberts
who are absolute pure mathematicians and
they reveled they they
i mean this this world so most people
just life to them
and and basically i was a dumb engineer
i was a i was
i was a dinosaur but my business
was not to know the work that they did
to the level they did
my job was to be able to ask the right
questions
and watch the clock i counted cadence
for mission control so most people who
only see the astronauts have no
concept that of all this that's going on
behind the scenes that's making it
happen in the first place
well the the mission control team has
the responsibilities for planning
training and
training and operate and when we have
problems during the course of the
mission we have to come up with
solutions that allow you to continue
with the plan that you had
and if that is not possible to come up
with another plan that is just about as
good
one last question what's the primary
goal you think nasa should have going
forward i believe nasa should
go back to the moon and then on to mars
i i believe that it's very important
you know to me the moon is like the
boundary in the mississippi river we've
been across there a few times
but really think about the development
that took place out west think about
lewis and clark going out to the pacific
think about the business of exploration
and those things that we learned and
developed and discovered out there
but most importantly i think it is a
human thing exploration
is a process that must be in every
person's mind it has to be part of their
personality it has to be the kind of
thing
that makes them want to get up and go to
work each day
and discover so
back to the moon onto mars and beyond
that's right
you got it go for launch okay
excellent there's only one gene krantz i
effing love that guy i love
him you want that to be the voice in
houston when you were in the universe
somewhere i want that to be the voice of
everything that guy amazing will be okay
you will be fine i'll tell you what
you're going to be you're going to be
absolutely terrific that's what you're
going to be
neil i want to tell you i like coffee i
like my
coffee as black as space but i use the
stars and stripes as the sugar
in my coffee and i wake up every morning
to coffee and stars and strips
it's tremendous that's america that's
what it is
that is awesome
that dude is awesome he's he's really
the guy that
you want looking out after your ass
when you're up there in space you want
to know that you're the man in charge uh
is gonna
make sure you're okay and he's gonna is
gonna consider it
he didn't mean god in that case the man
in charge
no the man in charge what i really mean
is the flight director right the flight
director is the person who oversees the
team
that is looking out for you and you and
that's what i always felt you have a
certain
um a certain uh connection with
the your launch flight director in this
case i think gene was the launch flight
director
for and mike linebeck was a guy that
launched us out of ksc and then our
launch flight director
my second mission norm knight and tony
soccer was our the guy during the orbit
and there was those
they they had an orbit guy we had an
orbit guy he was an orbit guy for apollo
11 as well right
yeah but but they all followed i think
in gene's steps
and uh and that was and that was what
you wanted you wanted someone it was
the right stuff make sure you were
coming back the right stuff wasn't only
the folks who flew it's the folks on the
ground yes and they take it just as
personal when something happens as
as anyone else involved they're there
their job is to bring you back
more than anything no you want a guy
like that
but i know where that saying comes from
what's that failure is not an option
people say that all the time right you
didn't know what
get it on audiobooks
chuck is like his eyes are popping out
yeah yeah i love that guy like
this dude he's like 76 right there when
you're chilling
he's in and even at 76 and you're
talking to this guy he sounds like a 22
year old kid right with excitement
and right right i love that mike did
they level with you what your risk of
not coming back
was because they made a point of this in
first man
that these risks are real and we saw
others die
apollo 1 three astronauts died on earth
wow
they're test pilots who have died so
this is a specter over your choice to
participate
uh uh yeah i think they tried to be as
accurate as they could and all about it
yeah and i remember it more uh because i
was i flew on columbia as a
the mission right before we lost
colombia and then i flew
uh again after on atlantis uh
both shuttle flights and i don't
remember if what the
there wasn't as much talk beforehand i
guess it wasn't maybe as much on our
mind as it was
after the accident we lived through that
after the columbia after columbia
but the number i remember being told was
about one out of 75 chance
and they weren't saying we want you to
know this number it was more like this
is our new calculated probabilities
well i think it was one out of 75 and
that was total destruction
that's that's loss of crew and vehicle
that's everyone's dead
and the vehicle can't be used again
there are other odds that that may be of
of they folded the odds of reusing the
vehicle with the odds of you coming back
alive
yeah it sounds pretty good but it's it's
but it's true i mean
i hate to put it that way but when we
lost when we lost colombia we just
didn't lose our seven friends we also
lost the spaceship and what happened to
the program so right
okay there's a loss of crew and vehicle
now losing but but
it's not so much about this really isn't
crass i don't think because you can lose
the vehicle but save the crew so if you
have an abort with the shuttle
and it ends up in the water as you abort
hopefully the crew gets out alive so
it's a combination of loss of crew and
vehicle was about one out of 75 and as
it turned out
we had two accidents at 135 flights
that's one that's probably how they came
up with that number quite honestly but
uh
it was one out of 75 total losses and do
you think about it at all when you're
or are you just too busy doing your
appointed duties to even
let it cross your mind i i took a flight
back to new york from detroit yesterday
morning
and the whole time i was like god i just
hope these people know what they're
doing
um sometimes you're wearing more on a
commercial flight than you are doing
anything yeah
i believe we had it you know no yeah
absolutely i i did i don't know if
everyone does but i
i knew that uh that there was a very
good chance that something
might might it might you might not be
coming back and
uh i think it's it's uh in some ways
that's a
that's a good thing to know because the
movie captured this
poignantly with his relationship with
his wife and his kids yeah and
i think they also showed the after was
successful
how wonderful it was forever to have
that exactly we have succeeded
yeah we have succeeded and alan being
tells us the story
uh that after his after after apollo 11
after his mission it wasn't uh the whole
world
his his impression was the whole world
it wasn't like you did it or the u.s did
it but
we did it we the human human species
yeah that motto they came for all
humankind let's change it a little bit
right for all humankind
uh i think that's the way you come in
peace becoming peaceful humankind
yeah and that's why i think people felt
about it it was a an accomplishment
that for that humans that showed what we
could do
in the whole world was was a part of it
and they felt it was
an accomplishment for the world i was
had the privilege and honor to be
invited to
neil armstrong's funeral service in in
ohio
after he died and the they had
the remaining sort of moonwalkers were
there and
the moment was solemn of course but it
was also
celebratory there were reflections on
neil as a person
and one thing that came across and let
me we're running out of time let me sort
of end on these thoughts if i may
was yeah neil was the right guy for this
job
and because
if he started grandstanding this
achievement
then it would be like he
landed on the moon but in fact we all
landed on the moon
it's our collective first step
on the moon tens of thousands of
engineers and scientists and
hundreds of millions of taxpayers
we landed on the moon and
what did he do when he was done he
became
citizen armstrong again became a
professor
went back to ohio where so many
astronauts have come
became a professor just and shunned
interviews
and i'm reminded it was roman
roman emperor cincinnatus
cincinnatus after whom cincinnati his
name cincinnati ohio
that's what he taught he
he came to become emperor and when he
was done
he went back home and continued as a
farmer
didn't exploit the fact that he ran all
of rome
he didn't grandstand that fact
he was called into service he gave of
himself his time his energy
sacrificed whatever was necessary for
his home life when he was done
he went home
that's what neil armstrong did he came
home to us all
it's pretty cool man i have to say uh i
understand it for neil armstrong
cincinnatus got a problem with him what
what's your problem with since
i'm just saying you know you were ruling
all of rome and then you became a farmer
what's your problem buddy you kidding me
the roman empire
roman empire at your disposal it's a
reminder of
farming it's a reminder that some people
want power for power sake
rather than power to lead and guide
others in a time of need
we got to end it on that mike massimino
thank you always
great thank you man and thanks for doing
this for neil uh
i think for neil armstrong he is uh i
think the things you said especially at
the end there i think those are those
the lessons we can learn
for all of us no matter what your
occupation is how to approach things
and uh he was my hero as a little boy
because he landed on the moon but
getting to know him a little bit as a
person and learning more about him
that's when you realize
what a true hero he was so thanks for
doing this and having me a part of it
and chuck gene krantz is his hero now
yeah
i'm just so happy about the cincinnati
guy cincinnati
that is all i'm saying this has been
star talk uh
most of you are listening some of you
are watching uh i've been your host neil
degrasse tyson as always
keep looking up thanks to
curiositystream for supporting this
episode of star talk
if you're watching this neil armstrong
episode of star talk you're probably a
fan of the apollo mission and space
travel
curiosity stream has over 2 500
documentaries and non-fiction titles for
you to enjoy
many of which will be right up your
alley it's just 299 per month and if you
go to curiositystream.com
starttalk and use promo code star talk
your first 31 days are free
as i told you earlier you should check
out return to the moon to see how we
might get back to the moon
for good that sounds like a threat also
you'll want to check out the series on
space probes
their video about the first captured
photograph of a black hole
and stephen hawking's multiple
award-winning shows
all of that is just 299 per month
get it at curiositystream starttalk and
use promo code star talk for your first
month free